Facebook looks to the government to help
censor viewpoints the old guard
Democrats clash with the Socialists and
we checked the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show oh man a
lot to get to today I want to thank you
again we are in the third week of
release for the right side of history it
continues to chart in the top three
non-fiction books over at Amazon it was
number three on the New York Times
bestseller list and its second week it
was number one in its first week so
thank you so much for going out and
buying the right side of history and
letting your friends know about it I
think it's an important book we're gonna
get to all the news today in just one
second first let's talk about something
we can all agree on saving money
okay the reality is that if you are not
shopping around then you are probably
not saving money well what if there was
some way that someone would do be
shopping around for you well that is
exactly what the Honey best price finder
does with millions of sellers on Amazon
selling the same products the only way
to know if you're really getting the
best price is honey's best price finder
automatically compares the prices of
millions of sellers that carry the item
that you want honey even factors in
shipping sales tax and Amazon Prime
status to make sure that you are getting
the lowest a total price it shows you
the best deal every time even if Amazon
does not it's like having your very own
smart shopping assistant I'm buying
stuff from Amazon legitimately all the
time books kitchen products legitimately
the exercise stuff stuff from Amazon all
the time I've saved a lot of money using
honey and the beautiful thing about
honey is you don't even know that you're
really using it until it just saves you
money more than 10 million people are
using it they have over a hundred
thousand five-star reviews on the google
chrome store next time you are shopping
on Amazon treat yourself to the free
upgrade that guarantees you always get
the absolute best price here's how it
works you add honey for free at join
honey calm slash man they just forget
about it and it runs while you're going
shopping I mean it's really amazing go
to join honey calm slash burn honey is
the smart shopping assistant that helps
you save time and money
join honey calm slash Ben and you can
add honey for free when you use that
slash Ben join honey calm slash Ben
honey the smarter shopping assistant
that helps you save time and money so I
do want to get to the 2020 presidential
race pattern begin today was something
that is really deeply troubling and that
is you are starting to see social media
instead of looking at the government as
an opponent in its free speech mission
a regulatory body that is seeking to
quash its creativity
we have now moved from social media as
capitalist countries to companies to
social media as government enabled
companies that is where these these big
companies are seeking to go there's this
grand failure to understand how exactly
big business sometimes works people tend
to say well big business rapacious
exploitative capitalist pigs here's the
reality big businesses are in the
business of profit seeking when you have
a giant government and that giant
government can increase your profit
margins by issuing regulations companies
will work hand in glove with the
government corporatism is not in fact
fair use of the free market it is not in
fact use of the free market at all it is
use of the government to do your bidding
for you and once the government is so
big that it can threaten your company
then many companies have a binary choice
and that is they can either work hand in
glove with the government to help quash
their competitors and they can say they
are friends to the government or they
can fight the government you see this
historically with for example the car
companies so Henry Ford famously
resisted the the unionization efforts at
Ford he resisted the government crammed
downs of the of the FDR administration
he did not want to abide by their rules
and regulations and he fought them tooth
and nail whereas other car companies
just went along with the government and
Ford kept losing market share because of
all of that well the same thing is
happening right now in the social media
sphere basically there are all these
major social media companies and the
government government actors see power
in regulating a lot of these major
companies and so the major companies
have two choices one is they can fight
the government they can go to the public
and say listen you need to tell the
government to lay off and leave us alone
or the easier path is often to go to the
government and say listen regulate us
but when you do regulate us understand
that what you're really doing is
regulating everybody else was smaller
this was a lot of the net neutrality
debate there were major companies on
both sides of that debate
Google for example is very much in favor
of net neutrality because it prevented
broadband carriers from charging them
for things that it essentially crowded
lower down competitors out of the search
engine market that's why Google is in
favor of net neutrality wasn't out of
any goodness of their heart or anything
big companies have an interest in
working hand in glove with the
government well the latest company to do
this is of course
Facebook so Facebook is now begging of
the government to censor it
I am not kidding you Facebook once
censorship at this point so Mark
Zuckerberg was on with George
Stephanopoulos and he says that he wants
the federal government to regulate
speech why because he recognizes that
Facebook is getting beaten up for its
own failures too on the one hand censor
speech and on the other hand they censor
too much speech so what he wants to do
is kick the responsibility over to the
federal government and thereby remove
himself from the process this is what he
says to George Stephanopoulos he poses
this in terms of the public good he says
I want more regulation in my company
whenever somebody who's the head of a
company says I want the government to
regulate my company understand there's
an ulterior motive and the ulterior
motive is almost always I want the
government to do something that will
make my bottom line more lucrative while
shielding me from the government's
actual intervention here Zuckerberg
doing exactly that there was a question
of what decisions should be left to a
private company to make especially where
in things like speech and expression for
so many people around the world and
where should we have either industry or
more government regulation you're
already seeing the FCC push back fairly
hard against these two commissioners I
think saying no we don't want to get
into the business of policing the First
Amendment yeah I don't think that that's
what this is though well I think it's
you can say that cut any regulation
around what someone says online is is
protected but I think that's clearly not
right today you know it's not clear to
me that we want a private company to be
making that kind of a fundamental
decision well this is really funny
because Zuckerberg like a year ago was
saying that's the kind of decision that
we will make we will take responsibility
for these decisions and that's because
he was called on to the hill by
Republicans and Democrats and then he
was run through the wringer about all
the stuff that was appearing on Facebook
now his correct answer should have been
to say to Congress hey guys it's not my
business what appears on Facebook
Facebook is just a platform if people
put crappy stuff up there that I don't
agree with that's not my business you
know I would prefer they not say that I
would prefer that people rebut that but
I am NOT going to sit there as the giant
social media censor and shut down
messages I don't like the good that I
have provided for American citizens and
people around the world is a forum where
they can exchange ideas the good is not
my particular perspective on politics so
oh I'm going to do is create algorithms
that ferret out violent content threats
of violence
defamatory material actual legal
violations that's the stuff I can police
but I can't police generalize political
viewpoints but that is not what the what
the government wanted from Zuckerberg so
Zuckerberg is responding by trying to
kick them all back to government he's
trying to say to government okay fine
you know what I have the same goals that
you do I don't want any of this
politically incorrect or badminton like
legitimately bad material on my site so
you guys regulate it
you guys come after me and that way it's
not my fault that way it's your fault
well that's not the role of government
and it's very dangerous to have folks in
corporate life or very powerful like
Zuckerberg calling for this to be the
role of government because you could see
a world in which House Democrats take
Zuckerberg up on this they say you know
what our social media companies have
declared that they can't do anything
about the white supremacy online the
white nationalism online and now it's
our job to do that well no it is not
your job to do it there's a First
Amendment to the Constitution that
guarantees in fact that Congress shall
make no law respecting the abridgement
of speech okay that is part of the First
Amendment
so when Zuckerberg explicitly calls for
a violation of the First Amendment by
the government in response to his own
inability to police his own site that's
a problem that's a real problem and
here's the again here's the real reason
he is doing this the real reason he is
doing this is because in Europe there
are now regulations coming down the pike
that would punish mark zuckerberg for
bad material appearing on his website he
doesn't want the responsibility of
having to censor his own website after
saying he would take responsibility
again
the answer to all of this was for
Zuckerberg always to say I created a
platform I'm like AT&T all I did was
provide a forum where people can talk
instead Zuckerberg because he wants to
be seen by his friends a do-gooder
instead he has said no I will be one of
the great policemen of speech and now
he's saying I want the government to do
it so I don't have to take the blame for
it again this is more in response to
pressures from government than it is in
response to an actual necessity on
Facebook for censors to shut down speech
why because here's what they are doing
in Europe according to a leaked plan
from the United Kingdom social media
bosses could be liable for harmful
content according to the Guardian social
media executives could be held
personally liable for harmful content
distributed on their platforms there's
been growing concerns it's going to the
Guardian about the role of the Internet
in distribution of material related to
child abuse self-harm and suicide and
ministers have been under pressure to
act under plans expected to be published
on Monday the government will legislate
for a new statutory duty of care to be
policed by an independent regulator and
likely to be funded through a levy on
media companies in other words they're
going to tax Facebook to police Facebook
and the way they're going to police
Facebook is by finding or jailing people
like Mark Zuckerberg if they do not take
a quote-unquote duty of care to prevent
bad material from getting on their
platforms it seems to me the reason we
pay taxes is is so that the police can
prevent crime we don't shut down phone
lines because criminals often use phones
and we don't hold the AT&T responsible
for criminals using their phones it is
obvious that we've been treating these
social media companies not as common
carriers not as platforms instead we
have been treating them as actual
editorial sites and that's why we're
there seeking to blame people like
Zuckerberg the regulator likely
initially initially to be something
called Ofcom but no longer from a new
body will have the power to impose
substantial fines against companies that
breach their duty of care and to whole
individual executives personally liable
the debate has been sharpened in recent
months by the case of the British
teenager Molly Russell and the issues
raised by the Christchurch shootings
Molly's parents said she killed herself
apparently because of self-harm images
viewed on social media it will self-harm
images are not threats of violence
they're horrible they're terrible but it
is up to individual people not to look
at things that are going to hurt you
unless it is an actual attempt to hurt
you right the rights come along with
duties rights come along with
responsibilities if we as individuals
can't be trusted to participate in a
free speech society the answer isn't to
curb free speech the answer is that we
better do some introspection and figure
out how we are utilizing our free speech
in a bad way other proposals in the
online muharram white paper include
government powers to direct the
regulator on specific issues such as
terrorist activity or child sexual
exploitation annual transparency costs
or transparency reports from social
media companies disclosing the
prevalence of harmful content on their
platforms what exactly constitutes
harmful harmful content are we going to
have the US government determining what
content is harmful especially when in
New Zealand they're legitimately it
something to prosecute people for
reading a manifesto online is that
something we want the United States the
manifesto is evil of the Christ Church
shooter do a lot of people prosecuted
for downloading it and reading it so
that they know what's bad do we want the
same people who think that it is a good
thing that Jordan Peterson's was book
was temporarily banned from white coals
a bookseller in New Zealand over the
Christchurch shooting those would be the
same people sitting on boards like this
and that is what Mark Zuckerberg is
calling for it's incredibly dangerous in
Europe obviously they don't have the
same sort of free speech protections
which is one of the reasons I'm
incredibly glad I'm an American both
right and left in Europe are far more
comfortable curbing free speech than we
are in the United States Theresa May has
repeatedly raised the issue of online
harm the government has gradually
shifted its position in Britain from
favoring voluntary self-regulation to
backing tougher enforcement and why is
this good for for Zuckerberg because now
Zuckerberg can simply say it's not in my
hands
the government is regulating it I just
have to comply with government
regulations all the free speech issues
are kicked over to the government level
the only losers in this American
citizens and citizens abroad who are now
subject to the government deciding what
messages they can and cannot see this is
dangerous stuff in Zuckerberg is not the
creator of the danger but he is
complicit in the increase of the danger
if he doesn't stand up for the free
speech the the sort of free speech basis
for the platform that he built in the
first place I'll get some more of this
in just a second the tech companies
caving to kind of social justice
warriors and then looking to hand it
over to government is pretty amazing
we'll get to it in one second first
let's talk about your sleep quality
there's nobody on the planet like you so
why would you buy a generic mattress
built for everyone else helix sleep is
built a quiz it takes two minutes to
complete they use the answers to match
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress whether you're a
side sleeper or a hot sleeper whether
you like a plush or a firm bed with
helix there's no more guessing and no
more confusion just go to helix sleep
calm slash Ben take their two minutes
leave quiz they will match you to a
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life for couples helix can
even split that mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they've
got a 10 year warranty you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free these
mattresses are incredibly comfortable my
wife and I have one we took the
two-minute sleep quiz they personalized
the mattress just for us and then you
jump on every night it is fantastic it
is it is incredibly comfortable it's so
good that I got one for my sister for
her wedding as well right now helix is
offering up to 125
of all mattress orders get up to a
hundred twenty-five bucks off at helix
sleep comm slash Ben that's helix sleep
comm slash Ben for up to one hundred and
twenty five dollars off your mattress
order helix sleep comm slash Ben go
check them out right now
helix sleep comm slash Ben they are
fantastic really I mean the mattresses
are incredibly comfortable and not
nearly as expensive as some of the stuff
that's worse they're gonna get at a
mattress store already speaking of
social media companies botching their
job Google on Thursday announced that it
optimizes what happened well a Google
spokesperson in a statement said Google
is going back to its drawing board why
it became clear that in the current
environment the council can't function
as we wanted so we are ending the
council we're going back to the drawing
board Google had announced its new AI
Ethics Board a body tests with serving
as an ethical check on Google's AI
technology production last week the
board was immediately met with
controversy as thousands of Google
employees and hundreds of external
petitioners took issue with one of the
boards members who they said had an anti
trans and anti-immigrant record who was
this cake hole James was president of
the Heritage Foundation that is a
mainstream conservative organization and
cake hole James is about as mainstream
and conservative as you can find but
because she believes that men are men
and women are women and she believes
that we should have border security this
means that she cannot be present in a
hearing between multiple viewpoints
about AI ethics a petition from Google
employees signed by almost 2,400 of them
said by appointing James Google elevates
and endorses her views implying that
hers is a valid perspective worthy of
inclusion in its decision making this is
unacceptable in other words her views
are not even valid they are not even
valid so what did Google do instead of
standing up to the own internal mob
these are other employees instead of
them standing up to their own internal
mob and just saying guys cool your jets
have a wide variety of perspectives on
this panel this is a mainstream
conservative pounced and instead they
caved and they disbanded their own board
these tech companies are just they're
just cowards there are legitimately
cowards they won't stand up for freedom
of speech or diversity of opinion on
their own internal boards let alone in
their public policy and now they are
calling for the government
and regulate and of course who will that
affect the most it'll affect
alternatives because if you regulate
Google or you regulate Facebook let's
say that there's a new Google or
Facebook who wants to come up and they
don't want to regulate speech in the
same way that Facebook and Google do
they want to have a broader platform
it's too late the government's already
regulated the entire industry so it's
now impossible for you to actually
create an alternative to Facebook or
Google once the government regulates
this sort of stuff by the way then you
are looking at true monopolies you
really are people have said well
shouldn't we break up Google or break up
Facebook and I've always said no these
are private private companies rivals can
crop up and those rivals could take a
different viewpoint on how to build an
algorithm or what kind of free speech to
allow it's a private company once the
government regulates that is no longer
the case then you have to start
regulating these things like monopolies
because effectively they are the AI
ethics council is over and we did this
together the Googlers against
transphobia account tweeted so many
people answered the call to stand
against transphobia we thank you for
your support and unwillingness to
compromise on hate one of the council's
members dropped out almost immediately
after the council was announced leading
behavior economists and privacy
researcher Allison throw a quiz see last
week tweeted I'd like to share that I've
declined the invitation to the council
well I'm devoted to research grab them
with key ethical issues of fairness
rights and inclusion in AI
I don't believe this is the right forum
for me I'm Wednesday another one in the
council members Luciano Florida Florida
a leading AI expert wrote that James's
inclusion was a grave error and sends
the wrong message in other words any
conservative cannot be part of the
Google Board I mean this this sort of
top-down idiocy
at these major social media companies
combined with government power turns
this from a government from a company
sucking at its job to an actual monopoly
issue
alrighty meanwhile the 2020 race is
heating up there no less than 18
potential Democratic candidates who want
to jump into the race and the list just
goes on and on and on there's a top tier
the top tier is probably four or five
people basically Biden Bernie Bay dotes
three B's plus Kamala Harris that I
would say that that's probably the top
tier in the Democratic Party right now
my polling data that's the top tier in
the Democratic Party right now and Biden
is the one who is in trouble
shockingly enough without any real
rationale I gotta say like again because
he did not have the courage of his
convictions because he was unwilling to
simply come out and say listen I've
never sexually harassed anyone I've
never sexually abused anyone and if
people were offended I'm sorry I'm just
a physically affectionate guy instead of
him just saying that and letting it go
he has a kowtow to the mob it's not
going to stop once you count out of the
mob it never stops ever you never
apologize to the mob is the rule of
modern American politics if you don't
apologize to the mob like Ralph Northam
you're still governor of Virginia if you
do apologize to the mob like Al Franken
you no longer have a senate seat that's
the way this works it's unfortunate but
that is the way that it works and we are
now supposed to take seriously every
allegation of something terrible
happening I mentioned yesterday one of
the allegations from a woman named
Sophie karasek a survivors rights
advocate and progressive organizer who
appeared at the Oscars with Lady gaga
and she now has a piece in The
Washington Post called a photo of me and
Joe Biden went viral I want him to take
ownership for his actions this is the
one I talked about yesterday where this
lady took the photo had it printed had
it framed put it on her bookshelf and
then decided to year to two to three
years later that it was actually a very
very bad thing very very bad she
apparently had she apparently interacted
with Biden two months later at a
conference in Colorado she said quote I
was eager to tell him about the good the
photo had done so I zipped in line to
greet him Sophie he exclaimed and we
talked about the photo the interaction
was completely normal I felt proud then
but as time passed I began to feel the
sense of shame and belittlement every
time I saw the photo so over time it
started to offend you and this is Joe
Biden's fault no one can live by these
constantly shifting standards in the
Democratic Party he really the there's
this moment in the new not very good
Star Wars movie in the last Jedi where
kylo Ren who is the bad guy turns to Rey
who is the MarySue good character and
they are there fighting together for a
brief moment in time and kylo Ren turns
to Mary Sue and Jew to rent a race re
and says to her and says to her you know
we should just kill all the oldies and
start something new and she's like no we
can't do that we totally can and then
they fight each other right
well that is basically what the
Democratic Party
is right now it's a battle between kylo
Ren and Rey it's the newbies saying
let's kill all the oldies let's go all
of them right sure they helped us build
this Empire sure they're the ones who
got us to where we are but they're
oldies man and they don't understand the
new wave now the thing about this sort
of mentality is that the revolutionaries
are usually the first to the guillotine
meaning that sooner or later these
people will be hoisted by their own
petard Biden is one of them by the way
he's one of the people who pushed for
lowering standards when it came to
proving sexual misconduct in title mine
cases for example but Biden is now being
shellacked by his own party for stuff
that even the people who were the
quote-unquote victims did not consider
victimization at the time that's how far
we have moved and the worm has turned I
mean Nancy Pelosi imal enough remember
when Nancy Pelosi was the great radical
inside her own party now she's the
establishment holding back the radicals
for example yesterday Bernie Sanders
tweeted this out he tweeted out those
who both were poles met the careful o me
to explain why our current failed system
should be allowed to continue
bankrupting the American people hey well
Nancy Pelosi comes out and she's like um
you know that medicare-for-all thing not
a great idea if he really opposes
medicare-for-all by the way if he's
upset with Medicare for all I mean for
with with opponents of Medicare for all
you know who she should talk to Joe
Biden and Barack Obama because Barack
Obama is the contestant he's criticizing
right there when Bernie Sanders says if
you stand for the current system you're
standing for high costs on people who
does he think constructed the current
system he voted for it by the way it was
Barack Obama and Joe Biden who as I
recall said to Barack Obama that the new
system was a big effing deal a phrase
that was so popular among Democrats that
it was sold on a t-shirt by the DNC it's
the old guard Democrats versus the
newfangled socialists this is why
Speaker Nancy Pelosi is out of step with
her own party she questioned today
whether a health care proposal embraced
by several Democratic presidential
candidates would be too expensive and
failed to provide the same coverage as
the Affordable Care Act instead she
suggested she'd rather build on
Obamacare is yet to be convinced the
medicare-for-all proposal pushed by many
liberals would achieve its purported
goals she said in an interview at The
Washington Post quote I'm agnostic
stick show me how you think you can get
there we all share the value of health
care for all Americans quality
affordable health care for all Americans
what is the path to that I think it's
the Affordable Care Act and if that
leads to Medicare for all that may be
the path she also suggested that
Medicare for all had become more of a
buzzword among political activists in
the run-up to the 2020 campaign which is
basically her ripping on all the 20/20
candidates saying you guys are ignoring
the effect of Obamacare so that you can
run for president she says when most
people say they're for Medicare for all
I think they mean health care for all
let's see what that means a lot of
people love having their employer-based
insurance and the Affordable Care Act
gave them better benefits which is not
actually true but sure the fact that
Nancy Pelosi has now been castigated as
out of the mainstream by her own party
is pretty telling the fact that Joe
Biden is now considered retrograde by
his own party demonstrates that when you
have no fundamental principles to which
you adhere it is pretty easy for you to
be cast overboard by the newer more
robust socialists among you it's pretty
incredible meanwhile President Trump
facing challenges of his own apparently
Michael Cohen now I guess he's trying to
cut a better deal or something he's
trying to delay his prison time
according to The Washington Times
president Trump's former personal lawyer
Michael Cohen says he has new
information to offer Democrats if
authorities reduce or delay his upcoming
three-year prison sentence first of all
I'm not sure what he thinks he's doing
this is I mean he is a bad lawyer
obviously but his plea agreement says
he's a he had to be completely
forthcoming with prosecutors all the way
through if he says that now he has new
material that means he was not
forthcoming before so they could
theoretically revoke his sentence and
give him a new longer sentence in a
letter to lawmakers on Thursday Cohen's
attorneys say he has discovered
substantial files on a hard drive that
could help investigations of the
president so now he's trying to become a
hero of the resistance the hard drive is
said to include over 14 million files
consisting of all emails voice
recordings images and attachments from
Cohen's computers and phones but Cohen
has already testified that he has no
actual evidence of Russian collusion
even though he is trying to float such
evidence now to Democrats according to a
memo that he apparently sent to
Democrats he said that he would provide
significant value to the various
congressional oversight and
investigation committees honestly this
may be more of a threat to Democrats
than it is to trump because Cohen
doesn't have much that is new but
Democrats could continue to spiral down
this this hole and never recover if they
focus in here I'm not sure that's a
smart strategy for them in just a second
gotta give you the justice Millette
update and then we'll get to some male
bagging because it's Friday
first let's face it Congress they stink
and the balance of powers that was
guaranteed by the Constitution of the
United States has completely fallen
apart in some ways Congress has
overstepped its boundaries regulating on
activities that have nothing to do with
Congress's original purview and in
otherwise Congress has kicked a lot of
power to the executive branch to the
regulatory bodies so that they never
have to be held accountable we need to
restore the checks and balances that
originally invested in the Constitution
the only way to do that is to call a
convention of states where we the people
can propose amendments those would be
amendments that could force changes to
the current balance of power that could
restrict the power of the federal
government to intervene in your life can
you imagine the look on the faces of
federal regulators and members of
Congress when they realize they can no
longer control your life as they once
wanted to calling a convention of states
is the only way to get the job done
there are already 3.8 million people
with us on this and more every day so
join me and Mark McClure and go to
convention of states comm /ban go sign
the petition today I know there are
people who worry about a runaway
convention the fact is that every
amendment still has to be approved by
two-thirds of the states so that's
really not an issue go to convention of
states calm slash been sign the petition
today that is convention of states calm
/ban help restore the original
constitutional checks and balances that
ensured limited government and our
freedom go to convention of states calm
/ been again almost four million people
with us on this already go to convention
of states calm / been and check it out
right now because obviously that balance
of power does need to be restored at the
first available opportunity already I
think what thirteen states have approved
the convention of states so go check it
out right now
and become part of the fight convention
of states calm / Ben all right
jussie Smollett update so apparently
jussie Smollett has now refused to pay
Chicago had sent Chelsea some allowed a
bill for like a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars which by the way he can
afford to pay
he made apparently about a hundred
thousand dollars in episode from Empire
well now the city of Chicago is going to
sue him last week the Cook County State
Attorney they dropped 16 counts against
Smollett of course the decision caused
an uproar in Chicago Mayor Rahm Emanuel
and other officials blasted the
prosecutor
office two days later the Sidney's
Department of Law sent some let a bill
in the amount of one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars and gave him a week to
pay up
that deadline expired on Thursday
afternoon the Law Department issued a
statement saying it was drafting a
lawsuit they said mr. Smollett has
refused to reimburse the city of Chicago
for the cost of police overtime spent
investigating his false police report On
January 29th 2019 the law department is
now drafting a civil complaint that will
be filed in the Circuit Court of Cook
County the law department will file the
suit in the near future as part of this
legal action the law department will
pursue the full measure of damages
allowed under the ordinance smollett of
course had falsely claimed that he was
jumped while walking on the street at
2:00 a.m. on the way back from Subway by
two white guys wearing red hats who used
racial and homophobic slurs and shouted
that it was Magga country and now and
now he is going to be sued for a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars meanwhile
the real scandal here is the is the
prosecutor in this particular case Kim
Fox who has significant political
connections to Team Obama yesterday the
police union called on Kim Fox to resign
her job we are here today we're very
grateful for the top police officials
who are here with one United voice to
demand the resignation of Cook County
State's Attorney Kimberly Fox this is
not just about Jesse Smollett this is
about many cases in the Cook County
system that have gone unprosecuted or
having charges reduced and what she's
doing is she's enabling the offenders
the bad guys are not being held
accountable so today we're here to ask
state's attorney Foxx to do the right
thing to step down and resign from her
position and this has been the commonly
held position among the police chiefs
all over the city of Chicago suburban
police chiefs and the Fraternal Order of
Police called out Kim Fox yesterday and
they suggested that she needed to resign
over the case a group of suburban police
chiefs joined with the Chicago Fraternal
Order of Police
they gave her a vote of no-confidence
Thursday the Fraternal Order of Police
President Kevin Graham and some other 30
suburban police leaders took it a step
further they called on Fox to resign and
that's what you just heard Fox's office
would not respond they said I was
elected by the people of Cook County to
pursue community safety prevent harm and
uphold the values of fairness and equal
justice I'm proud of my record into
I plan to do so through the end of my
term and if the people will so well it
into the future Graham's had the unions
issues with Fox's office didn't start
with Josie Smollett he expressed
frustration that Fox's office had
dropped murder charges against Gabriel
siwash and Arturo Reyes in late 2017
after a judge threw out their
confessions at the time Fox's then top
assistant said the office still believed
the two had fatally stabbed a couple in
their Bucktown neighborhood home in 1998
but had no choice to dismiss the charges
after the judge of discredited testimony
by a retired detective since mid 2016
about a dozen convictions tied to that
particular detective had been thrown out
of court because of allegations that the
former detective beat suspects and
coerced confessions apparently Fox had
this ticked off the Fraternal Order of
Police so yeah listen the Chicago Police
Department has had a bevy of problems
but that's really not the case when it
comes to this particular case this
police this particular smollett case was
interviewed all the way down to the
ground and the fact that Kim Fox decided
not to prosecute is pretty astonishing
meanwhile speaking of law and order the
situation on the border continues to
degrade the the crisis on the border
continues to move ahead we spoke
yesterday on the radio show with a
member of the Border Patrol down in San
Diego who said that the crisis was
essentially historic he said you'd never
really seen much like this tens of
thousands of people descending on the
border unmasked President Trump doesn't
really know what to do because nobody
knows what to do nobody really knows
what to do so the fact is that Democrats
are not providing the funding President
Trump needs the funding in order to
secure the border and media are now
beginning to cover this and so what did
Democrats do do they take seriously the
problems at the border no of course they
don't take seriously the problems at the
border so Lawrence Jones is a reporter
for Fox News okay he went down to the
border and he put on a flak jacket and
the reason he put on a flak jacket is
because in this particular area there
had been a case of 12 Mexican Marines
wounded in a shootout in the nearby area
this is like a couple of weeks ago this
is March 26 2018 from The Associated
Press
a Mexican marine and four suspected
gunmen were killed during a coordinated
series of ambushes against marine
patrols in a northern Mexico border city
authorities reported on Sunday so
Lawrence Jose goes to him there and he
is told by the Border Patrol put on his
flak jacket because we
don't know what weren't going to
encounter out there so what is a OC do
naturally fresh-faced alexandra Ocasio
cortez very fresh very face she tweeted
out does live from the border mean party
city fox is really out here doing the
most on a budget to make the border to
look more dangerous than it is and then
she tweeted the laughing crying emoji as
if the border is not a dangerous place
well Lawrence Jones responded he said um
yeah it is and there's a reason I am
wearing this bulletproof vest the Border
Patrol agent that's standing right here
keeping us safe told me to put it on to
keep us safe here what people don't
understand is that we control this side
of the border but the cartel controls
the other side of the border so there's
been gunfights I'm going in danger with
these Border Patrol agents to report on
this story if the public doesn't know
that over the last two and a half years
there has been an uptick over two
hundred percent violence against these
agents and so in order to do my job in
de Boer agents jump to do that job I had
to come with this vest that they supply
okay this is obviously true yeah I've
talked to people who are serving down at
the border and what they've told me is
there are cases where the the cartels
were on the other side of the border
they've got binoculars they've got eyes
on a lot of the Border Patrol agents
they will figure out who they are and
then they will call up their hotel rooms
and threaten them so this idea that the
border is a perfectly safe place that's
the myth that's the myth that the
borders are perfectly safe you literally
have an organized criminal outfit that
is killed legitimately thousands and
thousands of people in Mexico sitting
right on the other side of that border
and we're supposed to believe that it's
somehow out of bounds for a reporter to
wear a flak vest it's just insane it's
just insane you know Howard Schultz who
turns out to be maybe the only
reasonable person in the 2018 race I
mean is amazing the former CEO of
Starbucks one of the few sane people
apparently running for office and he's
seen because he's really not from the
political he's really not from a
political party at this point he pointed
out yesterday on Fox News that President
Trump is correct on securing the border
which is obviously an eminently true
president Trump is correct and the
Republican leadership is correct that we
need fierce strict levels of control on
that border to keep bad people from
coming in illegal immigrants should not
come in I don't want to get into a wall
or anything but I agree we should fund
whatever we need to do to secure the
border the Democrats are not correct we
should be funding ice and giving them
all the tools and resources they need to
secure the borders and arrest the bad
people okay that is of course true and
Howard Schultz is considered an outcast
from his own party because he says those
things I mean the Democrats response to
this effectively is not only should we
not police the border we should catch
and release everybody and when we
release them what should we do what
should we do with them how are we going
to integrate them into the American
economy we should teach them coding I am
not kidding you
ROH Khanna who is a congress person from
out here in California Democratic
Congress person from out here in
California he says that what we need to
do is bring everybody through and then
we can teach them coding why is this a
solution to everything except for
journalism if you say to a journalist on
Twitter learn to code they will suspend
you if you're a congress person who says
we should teach illegal immigrants many
of whom do not have a high school
education how to code then this is
somehow a solution to the border crisis
the numbers of people coming over has
increased that's a fact
Vanderbilt has done a study that one of
the real reasons that people are coming
over is an increase in violence I
believe we need to have US aid programs
that are working that are decreasing the
violence there that are teaching people
about coding so people stay there so
folks aren't coming across the border so
we're gonna teach them to code and
Honduras is the idea here
yeah the good solutions guys well really
what well well done that's that's
definitely gonna fix things okay in a
second we'll get to the mailbag first
let's talk about how you can alleviate
that back pain so it may sound kind of
weird but hanging upside down is
actually a pretty great way to
decompress the back and joints after a
workout and boost recovery you may not
know it but I work out on a regular
basis this is why I am just ripped but
that means that sometimes my back hurts
after workout 90 inversion therapy it
uses gravity and your own body weight to
decompress the spine and release tension
in your shoulders neck and joint over
three million people have put their
trust in teeter the teeter inversion
table is the best inversion table on the
market they've been the best known name
in inversion tables since 1981 and they
are offering a great deal just for my
listeners for a limited time you can get
a brand new 2019
spine inversion table model with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots so you can invert at home or take
the boots with you to the gym teeter
inversion tables have thousands of
reviews on Amazon with an average 4.6
star rating and with this deal you will
get 150 bucks off when you go to
cheaters.com slash pen that is te e ter
comm slash men you also get free
shipping free returns a 60 day money
back guarantee so what exactly are you
waiting for there's no risk to try it
out remember you can only get that new
2019 teeter Fit spine inversion table
plus a free pair of gravity boots by
going to teeter comm slash Ben that's te
e ter comm slash Ben I love teeter you
will to teeter comm slash Ben te ET ER
calm slash man go check it out right now
okay and a second we're gonna get to the
mailbag but first I need to remind you
that as a thank you to our daily wire
annual subscribers who are giving a
shout out to a different subscriber
every Friday today EJ Cronin on
Instagram we are thanking you for
supporting what we do in this photo it
appears that one of EJ students came in
with her leftist ears Tumblr and EJ put
her in a choke because she wouldn't
share the tumblr with him she now
realizes the chokes like facts do not
care about your feeling EJ thank you for
being a subscriber we really appreciate
it
if you want a chance at being featured
on the show become a daily wear annual
subscriber post a photo of your left is
tears tumblr on twitter or instagram go
check it out right now also make sure
that you subscribe for $9.99 a month or
99 bucks a year when you do you get all
the various glories we have talked about
so many times you get to join the show
for two hours in the afternoon we
sometimes answer questions during the
breaks we answer questions in the
mailbag we give you early access to the
Sunday special which this week is Andrew
yang I think it's one of our best Sunday
specials ever you get early access you
get that on Saturday plus questions that
you haven't heard behind the paywall all
sorts of goodies and you know we really
appreciate your subscribership so let's
get to the mailbag today we are not
actually cutting off the YouTube stream
so congratulations to you
the same thing with Facebook so let's do
some mailbag Josiah says hi Ben I listen
to much of your conversation with Joe
Rogan when you were talking about
decriminalizing marijuana it makes me
wonder how to sell this to religious
communities I had a good conversation
with my pastor about it well I think he
made a great point in saying if we were
to vote for decriminalization or
legalization he felt he would be signing
approval signaling approval for the
usage I tried to robot by saying when we
do things the right way or God's Way it
works then we're on drugs is a complete
failure I said it was sinful because we
as Christians weren't
good steward of God's money or resources
though he agreed who refused to ever
votes decriminalize or legalize
marijuana
most of the parishioners in my church
are much less open-minded to that
conversation I respect people's moral
opposition it just seems like a giant
waste of money to me see most people in
your synagogue disagree with you well I
would say there's a pretty broad
disagreement in in my synagogue and in
religious communities generally about
decriminalization of marijuana so what
is a good way to convince the religious
community that the government is
obviously not competent enough to deal
with the issue well I think that the
first thing that you have to recognize
is that just because something is bad
doesn't mean that the government gets to
regulate it I do not like using the
government as the imprimatur of
appropriate behavior I don't think
that's the government's role and in fact
I think it's been a huge mistake for
conservatives to use government action
as a sort of moral substitute for social
disapproval
so we disapprove of something therefore
we pass a law against it and then we use
that law to crack down on the behavior
and then when we fail it cracking down
on the behavior then we legalize the
behavior and now the moral imprimatur is
is taken away and people think it's okay
to do something I don't think that's how
we should view things I don't think
politicians are moral leaders I don't
think that laws are about installing a
quote/unquote moral system they're about
preventing harm to others installing
moral systems is something you do in
your home installing moral systems is
something you do in your religious
community yes there's more of an onus on
churches to take responsibility for
their members when it comes to the use
of marijuana or overuse or abuse of
marijuana if you were to decriminalize
it presumably it would become more
common in particular areas but that is
not an argument in favor of the
government simply enforcing your views
on someone who is doing no harm to
anyone else externality is the measure
of what a government ought to do so you
really ought to discover I mean you
really ought to to discuss what
government is there to do and then move
from there rather than talk about
whether it is moral or not to smoke pot
because I don't think these two
questions have to do with anything I
mean this is this is basically the
conversation that I had with with Joe
not only on marijuana use but also on
same-sex marriage I said that the
government does not have a role here
that does not mean that I personally am
in favor of same-sex marriage because
I'm not Stephen says hey Ben what are
you looking for in episode 9 to save
Star Wars or do you think there's no
hope after the last Jedi I think it's
very diff
to imagine a universe in which they can
recover from what they did not only in
the last Jedi but from force awakens
I thought force awakens was wildly
overrated I think that they should
honestly through it listen if they're
upset they're never gonna do this is a
billion-dollar industry
if it weren't for that they should throw
out episode seven eight and presumably
nine they should go back and they should
throw out a pisode x' one two and three
and they should start over as I've said
before what they should have done after
episode six is they should have either
skipped forward a hundred years and then
relaunched an entirely new Star Wars
universe or they should have actually
recast all of the characters after
Return of the Jedi I mean they did it
for solo and then just moved on with the
story that would have made a lot more
sense than simply killing off these
characters in the dumbest possible way
to make room for new and significantly
more boring characters I also they made
a huge mistake and not allowing Rey and
kylo Ren to team up there have been so
much more interesting so much more
interesting like this whole okay now
we're gonna revert back to kylo Ren as
Darth Vader and raise Luke it's we saw
that story already we don't need the
same story again ah deal says hey Ben
I'm writing a paper on affirmative
action what would you say is the biggest
issue with the policy specifically in
regard to post-secondary education well
there are two major issues with
affirmative action issue number one is
it doesn't actually tend to help the
people that it seeks to help there's not
a lot of data to demonstrate that
affirmative action has been effective in
increasing the upward mobility of people
who benefit from affirmative action
dropout rates are significantly higher
for people who get into college through
affirmative action it also creates a
broad spread perception a widespread
perception that people who are of the
race that is benefited from affirmative
action are somehow unqualified because
probably they got in or maybe they got
in or possibly they got in through
affirmative action it does create a
certain level of social stigma if you
look at your class and you say well I
know some of these people got in with
lower SAT scores and I can tell who they
are probably or at least possibly based
on race that creates an unfair stigma on
a bunch of people who may have gotten
and not based on that and that's really
not a great thing then there's the
question of who is being excluded by
affirmative action and typically it is
not actually white people it is Asian
people Asian people are outperforming at
major colleges across the country this
has been true of Harvard where a lawsuit
is now going on on the basis of all of
this using standard metrics is a far
better way of admitting students than
this ridiculous holistic exam
nation of your college essay so you got
200 points less on the SAT but you had a
hard life and so we are going to pretend
that that is the equivalent of an Asian
person who had a hard life but got 200
points higher on the SAT race does not
make up for performance when it comes to
these issues again if you have two
people when they have the same SAT
scores and one had a harder life than
the other race or not race has a factor
or not then fine I mean that's that's
good that person who has the harder life
has overcome more to get the same scores
but if you're talking about letting in
someone with a 1200 SAT to Harvard
because that person was of a particular
race that is obviously a separation of
human beings by race and an aspect of
racism that is quite unpleasant division
says Haven I've been a fan for years out
here in the Socialist Republic of Canada
it is more than the weather that is
bleak in our future I know you don't
follow Canadian politics who could
really but I'd like to know what given
the limited information you have now
what would you want for a Canadian
conservatism in the future well I think
that a Canadian conservatism would start
by pushing back against a lot of the
free speech encroachments that have
happened in places like British Columbia
where you could theoretically be
prosecuted for violating particular
political beliefs the same thing is true
I believe in Ontario with Bill c16 I
would start there and push back against
the idea that the government gets to
cram down on people what to think or how
to raise their children it's very very
dangerous stuff socialized medicine
obviously won't be touched in Canada
because once people are given what they
see as an entitlement they are very
loath to give it up but obviously
socialized medicine in Canada has some
serious serious problems such serious
problems that a part of Canada was
forced to recently open up the private
market because people simply were not
getting the care that they needed from
Canada's public market lower taxes
obviously it would be a factor in
driving more business to Canada I mean I
don't wanna remind Canada too much I
think Canada's pretty great place but
that's though those are a few
Corrections Jonathan says hey Ben
longtime listener first-time subscriber
I have a cousin who attends USC she
loves her time there however she's
afraid she's a die-hard ben shapiro
subscriber because she's afraid of being
criticized i know her story is not the
only one that breaks my heart I live in
Texas I'm starting to feel the same
pressures especially from Robert Frances
supporters that would be bad
do you see any end to conservatives
having to hide what they think in order
to keep their friends thank you for your
hard work keep up the good work well no
I don't see an end to that in fact I see
a sense
Boreas left that is looking to harm
people who disagree I have a great story
about this in fact from the college fix
today quote one evening last September a
Michigan State student university awoke
from his nap to see his roommate sitting
into his computer
there was a video playing and the
student realized his roommate was
watching a video of conservative
commentator ben shapiro the newly awoken
student then took to his own computer to
file a complaint with the
administration's biased reporting system
against his roommate from watching the
shapiro video ben shapiro is known for
his inflammatory speech that criticizes
and attacks the african-american
community the student wrote in his
report against his roommate i'd like to
see any evidence that i've attacked the
african-american community like
legitimate evidence he said I thought
hate speech I thought hate had no place
on MSU campus yet MSU has roomed me with
someone who supports hate speech spelled
SPE a CH ok Shapiro is a popular
conservative pundit says the college fix
whose appearances on college campuses
are frequently accompanied with protests
in response the university tests an
investigator to look into the matter who
is told to work for a room change if the
claimant would like one first of all if
I were the other student I'd be like
yeah I get this person out of here
because a person is crazy you know if my
roommate in college we're watching
Rachel Maddow I wouldn't file a
complaint and that's a near human rights
violation for goodness sake but know
that the tolerance is not going to be
extended anytime soon ruff houses hey
Ben I agree that abortion is a sin and
immoral however in my opinion the
government should allow it with proper
education in cases of rape the argument
that it is the person's responsibility
since they did not use contraceptives
and they chose to have sex does not
apply in rapes what is the pro-life
position in this case and in your
opinion is that our valid argument to be
made for this kind of policy well the
pro-life position is not dependent on
the quote-unquote responsibility of the
person because again the actual pro-life
position has to do with the status of
the human life growing in the womb it's
actually a separate question the
quote-unquote responsibility
responsibility adds to the mix in the
sense that if there is a predictable
result so the thing that you are
voluntarily doing and then that result
happens you can't throw up your hands
and go oh my god I was victimized by
life that's just silly but that's really
not what we are trying we're not trying
to punish somebody with a baby that's
not the idea here right is Barack Obama
said punishing somebody with a baby I
don't know baby but that that is not
what we are talking about we are talking
about protecting the life of an
we're talking about protecting the
incipient life of the baby and that
really has nothing to do with where the
responsibility lies it has to do with
the idea that you are not allowed to
kill a baby because the original in
creation of the baby was not your
responsibility in other words if
somebody hands me somebody leaves a baby
on my doorstep right and I open the door
and there's the baby
and then I shut the door and I just
leave the baby out there to die that's
not something that we should presumably
morally be okay with now in Western law
this is where this is one of the dicey
air issues in Western law in Western law
the question is is there a duty of care
that attends a person who you are not
related to right what is the duty so in
Western law we've been reluctant the
best argument for for abortion in cases
of rape is this argument effectively
which is if you're walking by a person
who is drowning you don't actually have
a responsibility under Western law to
jump in the water and save that person
even if you could do so pretty easily
there's no responsibility in Western law
so that's that could theoretically be
extended to cases of abortion in cases
of rape but the problem is that there's
a difference between not saving somebody
letting them die and actively killing
somebody so if the baby is on my front
door and somebody leaves the baby at my
doorstep and then I open the door and
it's not just me closing the door now
now to me actively stabbing the baby
that is now a completely different
question jim says hey Ben
lately I've been hearing President
Obama's administration has been
scandal-free could you go over some of
the top scandals people are forgetting
Thanks sure go read my book the People
vs Barack Obama I came out in 2014 - it
was sorry 2000 2015 I believe and that
book goes through a bevy of Barack Obama
scandals ranging from HHS to the IRS
he had scandals obviously having to the
NSA he had many many scandals during his
administration so go read the book I lay
it all out in detail there Nick says hi
Ben do you think Trump has a shot at
Virginia in 2020 where alph northerns
administration has been disastrous so
far could this push the state toward
Trump unlikely it's not a trump e state
Republicans in Virginia tend to be a
little bit more moderate than
Republicans in other conservative areas
of the country and Virginia has been
largely turned by Northern Virginia
which is effectively a DC
connor says what are the main
differences between Orthodox
conservative and Reform Judaism okay
Orthodox Judaism believes that the Bible
the Torah the five books of Moses were
given by God and that they are true and
that you and that the home eunuch
tradition that interprets the the Bible
is in fact good and proper law and that
you have to abide by the commandments of
the Bible because that is what you are
put on earth to do conservative judaism
original conservative judaism said that
basically the bible may have been god
inspired and that we could abrogate a
lot of the laws because those laws are
no longer relevant and said that the
rabbinic tradition is not nearly as
important as it has been in orthodox
judaism for a long time and reform
judaism honestly i'm not sure even what
the doctrine of reformed Judaism is at
this point they say that the torah may
not have been biblically and may not
have been god inspired it may be just a
historical document the bottom line is
that conservative used to be kind of
closer to what modern orthodox is now
now conservative the conservative
judaism has fallen into disrepair and
move toward reform judaism the only
growing area of judaism right now is the
orthodox community Glynn says dear mr.
Shapiro with all the left's talk about
abolishing the electoral college I
haven't heard about anyone talking about
the infringement of states rights are
there implication in that move to strip
the states of their status well
certainly there is an attempt to
downgrade particular states right nobody
would spend time in Wisconsin or or in
Michigan or in Pennsylvania outside of
the major urban areas if it were just a
popular vote and this is one of the big
arguments in favor of the electoral
college is that if you want to have a
country that holds together across a
disparate population you do need to give
a certain level of outsized impact to
people who don't live in city centers or
those people are simply gonna say listen
leave me alone
I'm gonna break away I'm not interested
in listening to what the people from the
big city want to do with my life we're
not part of the same community one of
the things that that keeps communities
together is a certain level of care that
is taken for people who are living
outside these sort of city centers and
levers of power see let's see Tory says
hey men love the show as you know the
left has pushed this idea that men and
women are completely the same and that
all gender roles are socially
constructed I do believe there are
gender roles that are socially
constructed
but I also believe a lot of feminine and
masculine attributes are human nature
can you say which gender roles you
consider to be social
construction and which you believe are
influenced by biology well you can tell
which gender roles are socially
constructed and which are influenced by
biology by looking cross culturally so
the fact is that women tend to be more
caring and affectionate they tend to be
more interested in interpersonal
relationships men tend to be obsessed
with objects and things and mechanisms
the the male tendency toward aggression
and violence is documented not just in
the human species but also in virtually
all mammalian species these are things
that are hardcore embedded the the sort
of cultural outgrowths of that have
manifested in various modes of dress
obviously the notion that women are more
nurturing that women are less physically
aggressive has manifested in sort of
prettier garments for women in most
cultures for example but as far as
gender roles that are that are sort of
constructed well I mean the idea that
women were not supposed to work at all
was an exaggeration of a perceived
gender binary and so the idea was that
women are more likely to want to be in
the home and they are the ones who bear
and rear children there's a certain
biological truth to that but that was
taken to the extreme by saying well
women shouldn't work outside the home
and obviously that's stupid so what has
very often happened is that gender roles
are based in reality but then they are
pushed too far to the point where they
become oppressive that's that's what has
happened very often patrick says haben I
wanted to ask you about the anti-israel
attitudes on college campuses when I was
in college I took a course on the
israeli-palestinian conflict and looking
back it was basically anti-israel
propaganda shocker this is what happens
on college campuses however at the time
I was a pretty far left student I bought
into it more readily only after learning
about the conflict in more detail did I
see the truth my question to you is a
why do you think anti-israel and
pro-palestinian attitudes dominate
leftist college campuses and B what can
people who support Israel do to combat
it also any book recommendations about
the conflicts you know would be great
okay a couple of book recommendations
there's one by Mitchell bard called
myths and facts it's also a really good
book out by David brog right now about
Israel's history so go search that thing
it's called re reclaiming Israel's
history I think is what is called that
what is it is a very good read those are
a couple of basic history books on the
conflict if you want deeper history
books on the conflict Michael Oren has
written several on the various Israeli
wars there's a great book called the
Prime Minister's about a person who was
present during virtually all of Israel's
history right
about it and it's really readable and
interesting so go check all of that out
the reason that anti-israel and
pro-palestinian stomp pro palestinian
attitudes dominate leftist college
campuses is because the left has a
widespread view that anytime you see a
rich person and a poor person the rich
person is responsible for the poor
person's misery and some they've looked
in the middle-east and they see a
westernized liberal powerful country
like Israel juxtaposed with a hellhole
like the Gaza Strip where a terrorist
group is in charge they want to
attribute that to Israeli exploitation
despite the fact that Israel abandoned
the Gaza Strip in 2005 despite the fact
that the vast majority of Palestinians
have been living under direct
Palestinian control for the last 20
years this is somehow Israel's fault
even though Palestinian terror groups
keep being elected and controlling the
governments in these areas and it's very
convenient batons wield against the
Jewish state which after all seeks to
survive only as Dennis Prager is fond of
saying if Israel put down all of its
guns tomorrow there would be no Israel
if the Palestinians put down all their
guns tomorrow there'd be a Palestinian
state alrighty let's get to some things
I like and then some things that I don't
so first thing that I like today there's
a movie that came out and was largely
ignored called Vox Lux now I understand
why it wasn't a popular movie but it is
one of the best takes on the
depredations of Hollywood and modern
culture that I've seen in a very long
time the basic premise of the film is
that there's a young girl who is going
to school in the late 90s and her
classroom has shot up in a Columbine
style attack and she herself is shot and
when she recovers she sings a song at a
memorial service and it becomes popular
and she ends up becoming a pop star and
the movie is basically about how she
falls apart as a human being thanks to
the predations of Hollywood and the
music industry and how we as a society
have decided to gloss over many of our
problems with the sort of happy talk of
pop music that sort of the air SATs
happiness that pop music is supposed to
represent it's kind of a deep meditation
it's not an enjoyable movie but it is a
really interesting movie so go check it
out Vox logs okay other things that I
like so I just have to pay homage to
this amazing nurse who has adopted a
baby at the hospital that had not been
visited for five months is according to
the Washington Post two years ago Liz
Smith director of Nursing at Franciscan
Children's Hospital in Brighton
Massachusetts was headed toward the
elevator
work when she saw her a tiny girl with
bright blue eyes in a single soft brown
curls swept across her forehead who's
this beautiful angel Smith asked the
nurse who was wheeling the infant down
the hall
her name is Giselle the nurse told her
the infant's a ward of the state had
been at the hospital for five months but
Smith had never seen her before
Smith learned that Giselle then eight
months old had been born premature at
another hospital in July 2016 weighing
just under two pounds
she had neonatal abstinence syndrome a
result of her birth mother using heroin
cocaine and meth during pregnancy the
state of Massachusetts to custody of
Giselle when she was three months old
and transfer her to Franciscan
Children's because her lungs needed
specialized care and she had a feeding
tube the baby didn't have a single
visitor in five months at the hospital
social service workers were trying to
place her in foster care and so Smith
decided to foster the baby and become
her mother she adopted the baby which is
just an amazing thing
you know folks who adopt are the great
unsung heroes in our society they truly
are it's an amazing amazing act of
charity it's a gift to the child and
it's a gift to our society when people
adopt this nurse is an amazing human
being and thank God there's so many I
know many parents who have adopted
they're doing something absolutely
incredible and providing for every baby
who requires a chance at a successful
life adoption needs to be made easier in
the country and and needs to be
facilitated by the state in a better
possible way ok one final thing that I
like so as you know I talked on the show
a lot about Burge school they're one of
our sponsors and one of the
representatives stopped by yesterday to
talk to me about the future of the
economy here's what that sounded like
well here we are on things I like and
one of the things that I like as you
know is Birch gold group we talk about
them all the time so much so that people
have memes about us in virtual group
while joining us from Birch gold group
today is Philip Patrick he's the senior
precious metal specialist over at Birch
gold group
Philip thanks so much for stopping by
thanks for having me so let's start with
this there's been a lot of talk in
recent months about the inversion of the
yield curve what exactly does that mean
and what does that indicate for the
future of the economy I mean it's it's a
really key sign that we have some some
tough times to come essentially the
yield curve charts interest rates on
bonds short versus long term and in a
normal climate what you expect to see is
shorter term bonds will carry lower
interest rates longer term bonds higher
interest rates and it's for obvious
reasons right I
somebody money today assess their
creditworthiness the chances of default
in three months fairly slim ten years a
lot of unforeseen circumstances
so I'll typically look for a higher
interest rate that's a normal climate
with the yield curve what we've seen
recently of course back in December some
of those metrics started to invert now
what that means is shorter term bonds
will carry higher interest rates than
longer-term bonds so it's a complete
reversal of that trend negative negative
sign right because what it implies is
that in the short term people don't see
opportunity right bad things are to come
so they're happy to tie their money up
longer-term even if it's a lower
interest rate a very negative sign so
what are some of the other signs that
we've been seeing I've seen a number of
reports about employment slowing what
are some of the other signs that you're
seeing in the economy about it sort of
slowdown in the economy that we can we
might be expecting here look a lot of
key metrics or reflecting bubbles and
and some bad things to come we mentioned
price to earnings ratios last time moves
here something we've been looking at
very closely recently is something
called a smart money flow index it's a
Bloomberg chart and essentially it's
designed to track institutional money
flows in and out of the stock market and
what we're seeing is a lot of
institutional money last year and
carrying on into this year flooding out
of the Dow Jones so a really really big
sign of tough things to come what I
think is even more interesting about the
chart it goes back to 1992 and it seems
to show the uncanny ability of
institutional investors to get out
because we saw the same trend before the
crash you know eight same trend before
the crash in 2000 so a signal of tough
things to come so Phillip what exactly
can we do to prepare for the possibility
of an economic slowdown look I I think a
big part of it is staying informed right
we're talking about looking at certain
metrics I think people a lot of people
like to bury their head in the sand
quite frankly and that can be a
dangerous thing it's not hugely
complicated it's a case of understanding
where opportunity exists and I think
making preemptive moves and as you and I
have discussed I think precious metals
for a portion
of one's portfolio in a climate like
this can work really really well there
contrarian in nature so the idea is if
we see losses on one portion it should
be the same climate driving growth in
contrarian assets so that losses could
be mitigated and this is what people
mean by diversification we'll talk about
diversification you're not talking about
everybody taking all their money and
putting into precious metals you're
talking about you should have your eggs
in more than one basket effectively
absolutely correct you wouldn't
recommend anyone taking all eggs and
putting them in any one basket but it's
diversification it's a measure of a
hedge that's exactly what we do so when
it comes to precious metals how they
perform historically versus the market
particularly in down times that's the
key actually look in times of economic
boom the stock market outperforms pretty
much everything else but it's in times
of correction right it's in times of
downturn that's when contrarian
safe-haven assets tend to perform and
you look at the last stock market crash
in 2008 we saw a 50 percent correction
in the Dow Jones and gold and silver
prices doubled in value in 18 months of
that so historically slow and steady
grows but in times of correction they
can perform very very well and you think
the economic indicators points you some
time in the near future a market
correction it looks that way well with
that said folks if you are interested in
diversifying the people you should be
talking to where my friends over at
Birch gold they have the 16 page free
information kit that you can go check
out right now birchgold.com slash Ben or
you can text Ben to 47 47 47 there's a
reason that I trust them they've been a
plus rating from the Better Business
Bureau and there's a reason we advertise
with them they advertise with us and
that's because of that mutual trust
relationship there folks that you can
trust they're gonna tell you the truth
about how much your money you should put
in they're not gonna try and oversell
you go check them out right now at
birchgold.com & Phillip thanks so much
for stopping by really appreciate your
time folks check out Birch gold group at
Birch gold calm / Ben okay time for some
things that I hate so let's just jump
right in
okay so it is worthwhile noting that
students for justice in Palestine
actually is a group that has ties to
terrorism they were just given an award
apparently at New York University the
presidential Service Award at NYU
despite the pushback we have received
from our institution we agreed that we
have made significant contributions to
the university community in the areas of
learning leadership and quality of
student life anyway New York University
divest from Israeli Apartheid okay these
the attempts to boycott Israel on
campuses is growing in stature it's
always fascinating to watch as groups
like students for justice in Palestine
which again do have ties to groups that
are associated with terror that those
groups are given all sorts of credence
despite the fact that students for
justice in Palestine is legitimately in
anti-semetic group and they it's amazing
instead of them doing Palestinian pride
week right there there's like Israel
Pride Week which happens on campuses all
over America instead of doing
Palestinian Pride week they do Israeli
Apartheid week because the goal is to
label the Israelis as a bunch of evil
racists despite the fact that Israeli
Arabs are treated better than Muslims in
any part of the Middle East bar none it
is not close despite the fact that Arab
parties sit in the Knesset despite the
fact that there's a Palestinian on the
Supreme Court of Israel none of that
matters Israel is the bad guy and so
they put out posters like this one for
Israel apartheid week in which it shows
a Palestinian who is throwing a like it
looks like a paint can a spray-paint can
at an Israeli and this is either causing
the Israeli enough a bump on his head or
the Israeli soldier has horns and is
following the Palestinian with a gun
because that's all that's happening
there is the people are spray-painting
and then the Israelis shoot them it's
not the terrorists are trying to break
through the border and murder Israeli
citizens or fire rockets into civilian
areas in the middle of Israel it truly
is astonishing and the sort of stuff is
not only tolerated on college campuses
which it should be I mean bad Roderick
should be tolerated on college campuses
obviously but it is promoted by the
administration in many of these cases
students for justice in Palestine
according to the Jerusalem Center for
public affairs has significant ties to
Islamic terror groups this is according
to the Los Angeles Jewish Journal the
JCP a report notes that the National SJP
organization was established in 2010 by
American Muslims for Palestine a MP the
US Palestinian community
network at the 2010 world Social Forum
EMP is chaired by Hitomi Bayesian who is
also the founder of students for justice
in Palestine Bastion has called for an
Intifada in the United States and has
referred to Israel as the slave master
additionally at least a couple of a MP
board leaders have ties to the Holy Land
Foundation a charity that was convicted
in 28 2008 for providing material
support to Hamas national SJP has also
provided a platform at their conferences
to the terrorist Raz Miyata who's
convicted by an Israeli Court for a 1969
Jerusalem supermarket bombing that
killed two students resmio died by the
way has also been praised by people like
Linda Sarsour the report notes that sjb
has been involved in a number of
incidents on college campuses throughout
the country including members of UC
Irvine's SJP getting arrested for
violent verbal disruptions of a
presentation by dr. Michael Oren the
former Israeli ambassador to the United
States things are very ugly in the
anti-israel community on college
campuses and that is something worth
taking note of okay well we will be back
a little bit later this afternoon with
two additional hours also this weekend
make sure to check out our Sunday
special with Andrew yang it really is I
think fascinating an interesting
Democratic presidential candidate we
hope to have more Democratic
presidential candidates on if they will
allow us to interview them it's really
nice discussion I think you'll find it
interesting and informative so go check
that out as well and make sure you're
looking for some we can we can reek end
weekend reading go check out the right
side of history my New York Times
bestseller my number one a national
bestseller go check it out right now and
we will see you here either later today
or next week i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show is
it white nationalism to expect
immigrants to assimilate of course not
but some people think seem to think so
we'll talk about that also a feminist in
a college newspaper wrote an article
saying that it is patriarchal oppression
to leave the toilet seat up it's pretty
hilarious we'll get into it and what
about the economic argument for abortion
that abortion helps the economy and so
on I will respond to that argument today
on the Matt Walsh show